Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Ahí estoy yo.
Nací en Quito, Ecuador.
Y creí en la ciudad.
Era una niña citadina
hasta que tuve siete años.
Fue entonces que mis papás
se mudaron a vivir en el campo,
en un valle que queda como
a 40 minutos de la ciudad.
Y es donde yo aprendí a sumergirme
entre los arbustos y en el monte
para explorar y observar insectos.
Pero, sobre todo, arañas.
Tanto me gustaban las arañas
que a mis 10 años
tenía una colección de 5000 arañas vivas
(Risas)
que coleccionaba en frasquitos de vidrio.
Sin dudas, esta era mi favorita.
En el mundo, 1 de cada 10 personas
tiene fobia a los insectos.
Y 3 de cada 10 tiene fobia a las arañas.
¿Ven esa carita de felicidad?
(Risas)
Yo no era una de esas.
Y entenderán que esquivar el bullying,
con una afición como esta en la
adolescencia, no era tarea fácil.
Así que hice lo que la mayoría hace:
Dejé mi afición para tratar de encajar.
Así que me gradué del bachillerato
especializada en física y matemáticas
y luego entré a estudiar diseño gráfico,
que era una carrera nueva en el Ecuador.
Y creo que fue una buena decisión.
Pero como en la vida todo
da vueltas, una madrugada,
muchos años más tarde,
regresaba manejando desde la costa.
Y a la altura del bosque nublado,
como a una hora y media
antes de llegar a Quito,
paré en esta pequeña estación
a cargar gasolina.
Y, de pronto, no podía creer
lo que estaba viendo.
Eran miles de polillas
pegadas en la pared.
Y otras que revoloteaban en la luz.
Enseguida me bajé y me acerqué.
Y fue cuando todo conectó.
Esa niña entomóloga frustrada
que había guardado y escondido
durante años salió a la luz y revivió.
Y fue cuando todo tuvo sentido.
Regresé a casa y decidí volver.
Escogí una cámara de fotos
un par de semanas más tarde
y regresé a la gasolinera.
Pero ¿qué creen que pasó?
¡No había una sola polilla ahí! (Ríe)
"¿Qué pasó? ¡No hay ni una!"
Yo no me imaginé esto; yo las vi aquí.
Resulta que las polillas,
cuando están dentro del bosque,
triangulan moviéndose
alrededor de la luz de la luna.
Pero en ausencia de luna,
o cuando es su etapa temprana
--menguante o creciente--
las polillas salen en busca de esa luz
y se van a las zonas pobladas.
Y es cuando se quedan triangulando
alrededor del foco.
Como todo el mundo me dice:
"¿Polillas? ¡Pero si son horribles!"
Es lo que Uds. están pensando ahora.
Sí, las polillas tienen fama de ser
una plaga, feas, peludas, oscuras.
Pero la verdad es que, como las vemos
detrás de la luz, siempre las vemos así.
Y cuando nos acercamos
a observarles encontramos
que esconden unos diseños fantásticos.
Por ejemplo, miren esta.
Esta es una de las primeras que vi.
Le puse de apodo Carolina Herrera.
(Risas)
Es muy hermosa, ¿no?
Vaca.
A esta le puse "La Cosidita"
porque es como que
tiene un pespunte alrededor.
Me encantaba. Y así iba encontrando miles.
Y cada una más hermosa que otra.
Desde los diseños más complejos
hasta unos inverosímiles.
Unos tornasoles, unos geométricos,
otros minimalistas,
más exóticos,
más caóticos...
¡había miles!
Y mientras yo les seguía observando
y admirando iba aprendiendo sobre esto.
Por ejemplo, ¿sabían que en el mundo
hay más de 150 000 especies de polillas?
Es muy loco pensar eso, ¿no?
Ojo que estoy diciendo 150 000
de polillas, no de mariposas.
A diferencia de las polillas
las mariposas son diurnas
y tienen un apéndice
al final de su antena
y cuando se posan
pliegan sus alas hacia arriba.
Las polillas,
que son en su mayoría nocturnas,
en las antenas tienen
una forma de plumita.
Y cuando se posan apoyan
y abren sus alas hacia abajo.
Y así comencé a diferenciarlas.
Yo las perseguía con mi cámara
y no perdía la oportunidad
para salir del trabajo e ir a observarlas.
Y ellas me posaban. Eran muy amigables.
A diferencia de las mariposas,
no salían volando sino que estaban ahí.
Yo les hablaba, les consentía,
les abría las alitas,
y cada vez se volvía más divertido.
Incluso mi familia y mis amigos
a veces llegaron a creer
que estaba un poquito loca... (Ríe)
porque les hablaba a las polillas.
Y creo que en la realidad, sí,
sí se volvió un poco una obsesión,
una pasión que no podía dejar de hacer.
Entonces dije, "tengo que hacer algo".
Y comencé a ilustrar digitalmente
estos bichitos.
Porque quería de alguna forma mostrar
esto que yo veía en la luz del foco.
Este movimiento, esta repetición.
Entonces comencé a hacer estos patrones.
Pero resulta que nadie me creía
cuando yo les mostraba esto
a los colegas, o a los amigos,
les decía
"¡Miren que hermosas estas polillas!"
"No eso no es real.
Son polillas, son feas".
Ni siquiera mis amigos biólogos
me creían realmente.
Entonces decidí hacer el mismo ejercicio
pero incluir las fotos,
para que no quepa la menor duda
de que eran reales,
que existían y que cada una
era más linda que otra.
Y así comencé a hacer este análisis
de la simetría de sus alas,
y de la composición, y observar
los detalles que tenían cada una,
iba jugando con el movimiento,
y con la cromática, que era fascinante.
Me encantaba ver
cómo hacían este contraste
con los lugares donde se apoyaban.
Por ejemplo, en la madera,
el cemento, el metal.
No eran esa mariposita, romántica,
que se va a la flor.
Eran estos seres un poco underground,
un poco urbanos.
Y esto hacía que se vieran
más lindos para mí.
Cada vez más hermosos.
Así que pasé cuatro años haciendo
esto en mis tiempos libres.
Y cuando tuve reunidas muchas,
dije, "voy a hacer un libro",
"voy a mostrarle esto a la gente".
Así que me aventuré a buscar editorial.
Y dije, "el libro se va a llamar ‘Pachanga’".
Pachanga porque
es sinónimo de fiesta, de rumba.
Y yo hacía esta analogía
con estas damas de la noche
que salían con sus bellos trajes
a bailar a la luz del foco.
Entonces fue que una editorial alemana
chiquita decidió tomar el reto.
Trabajamos un año más o menos
en la edición del libro.
Y cuando ya estuvo listo
hasta me sorprendieron diciendo
que lo iban a hacer en japonés.
Cosa que nunca me imaginé
que iba a pasar.
Pero lo que tampoco imaginé
es que mucha gente
después de esto me escribiría a decirme
que no volvería a matar una polilla.
Finalmente, las polillas mostrarían
y sorprenderían a muchos con su belleza.
Ese efecto de lo inesperado
se volvió una fuerza seductora
que causaba mucha curiosidad.
Y el libro pasó de ser
de un libro de diseño
a un objeto que invitaba a observar.
A observar cualquier forma de vida,
no solo polillas.
La gente observaba,
y luego se quedaba contemplando.
Y luego acariciaba las páginas del libro
generando esta experiencia
como de cercanía
y de hasta afecto con estos bichos raros,
que son invisibles.
Ahí es donde comprobé que las imágenes
tienen el poder de acariciar el espíritu.
Y para mí esta fue una
de las mejores recompensas.
¿Qué vino luego?
Comencé a hacer experimentos
para aplicar los diseños a objetos,
a productos y a otras cosas.
Pero, por otro lado, llegaron propuestas
para participar en proyectos editoriales
en colaboración con amigos biólogos,
fotógrafos, naturalistas y científicos
para, de alguna forma,
rescatar otros bichos raros.
Por ejemplo, sapos, ballenas, osos...
También me invitaron
a hablar sobre biodiversidad,
sobre cambio climático, sobre conservación
y sobre divulgación científica.
Y de alguna forma esto permitió
que yo siga con mi vuelo
con este viaje exploratorio donde
volví a hacer este ejercicio maravilloso
que es detenerme un rato
y acercarme a observar.
Y luego interpretar lo que veían mis ojos.
Tengo el privilegio de vivir en
un país megadiverso, que es el Ecuador,
que a pesar de ser un país chiquito
tiene muchos ecosistemas y microclimas.
Y mostrar a través de mi gráfica esa
abundancia, esa generosidad, esa riqueza,
y ese despliegue de formas y color,
hace que mi profesión
tenga sentido en mi vida.
Y es lo que me encanta.
Y en ese vuelo, siempre se me vuelven
a aparecer estos seres invisibles,
estos seres que nadie ve.
Mis arañas, por ejemplo.
O los insectos, que en el bosque
pasan desapercibidos.
Y es cuando me encanta ver los detalles
y volverlos a representar para
que la gente los vea en grande.
Y de nuevo regreso volando
hacia mis polillas,
que están ahí, que no se han ido.
Porque creo que hay pachanga
para rato y pachanga para todos.
Y es cuando reflexiono sobre
esa niña que un día dejó su afición
solo para no sentirse rechazada.
Y a la que ahora yo le diría que abra
sus alas y salga a explorar sin miedo.
Porque, después de todo,
no es tan malo ser un bicho raro.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)